do not do to others what you do not want
done to yourself
real knowledge is to know the extent of
one's
ignorance who speaks without modesty
will find it difficult to make his words
good
i hear and i forget
i see and i remember i do and i
understand
everything has beauty but not everyone
sees it
be not ashamed of mistakes and thus make
them crimes
isn't it a pleasure to study and
practice what you have learned
it is not possible for one to teach
others who cannot teach his own family
education breeds confidence
confidence breeds hope hope breeds peace
without feelings of respect what is
there to distinguish men from beasts
he who excels in study can follow an
official career
forget injuries never forget kindnesses
[Music]
we should feel sorrow but not sink under
its oppression
recompense injury with justice and
recompense kindness with kindness
better a diamond with a flaw than a
pebble without
[Music]
to love a thing means wanting it to live
to go beyond is as wrong as to fall
short
in a country well-governed poverty is
something to be ashamed of
things that are done it is needless to
speak about things that are passed it is
needless to blame
looking at small advantages prevents
great affairs from being accomplished
the people may be made to follow a path
of action but they may not be made to
understand
it when you have faults do not fear to
abandon them
the cautious cell dimer
men's natures are alike it is their
habits that carry them far apart
it is only the wisest and the stupidest
that cannot change
the object of the superior man is truth
the essence of knowledge is having it to
apply it not having it to confess your
ignorance
a man who does not plan long ahead will
find trouble right at his door
humility is the solid foundation of all
the virtues
anger rises think of the consequences
[Music]
study the past if you would define the
future
to be wronged is nothing unless you
continue to remember it
the scholar who cherishes the love of
comfort is not fit to be deemed a
scholar
wheresoever you go go with all your
heart
the real fault is to have faults and not
amend them
when we see mens of a contrary character
we should turn inwards and examine
ourselves
a fool despises good counsel but a wise
man takes it to heart
he who will not economize will have to
agonize
i am not concerned that i am not known i
seek to be worthy to be known
they must change who would be constant
in happiness and wisdom
[Music]
without an acquaintance with the rules
of propriety it is impossible for the
character to be established
mankind differs from the animals only by
a little and most people throw that away
to see what is right and not to do it is
want of courage or of principle
it is better to light one small candle
than to curse the darkness
respect yourself and others will respect
you
when prosperity comes do not use all of
it
ignorance is the night of the mind but a
night without moon and star
they must often change who would be
constant in happiness or wisdom
the more man meditates upon good
thoughts the better will be his world in
the world at large
we take greater pains to persuade others
that we are happy than in endeavoring to
think so ourselves
if a man takes no thought about what is
distant he will find sorrow near at hand
[Music]
behave toward everyone as if receiving a
great guest
what the superior man seeks is in
himself what the small man seeks is in
others
the strength of a nation derives from
the integrity of the home
when you see a worthy person endeavor to
emulate him when you see an unworthy
person then examine your inner self
[Music]
wealth and rank are what people desire
but unless they be obtained in the right
way they may not be possessed
the wheel of fortune turns round
incessantly and who can say to himself i
shall today be uppermost
the father who does not teach his son
his duties is equally guilty with the
son who neglects them
[Music]
the parents age must be remembered both
for joy and anxiety
when i walk along with two others from
at least one i will be able to learn
[Music]
if you look into your own heart you find
nothing wrong there what is there to
fear
study the past if you would divine the
future
virtue is not left to stand alone he who
practices it will have neighbors
think no vice so small that you may
commit it and no virtue is so small that
you may overlook it
do not worry about holding high position
worry rather about playing your proper
role
do not impose on others what you
yourself do not desire
acquire new knowledge whilst thinking
over the old and you may become a
teacher of others
sincerity and truth are the basis of
every virtue
review the old and deducing the new
makes a teacher
act with kindness but do not expect
gratitude
worry not that no one knows of you seek
to be worth knowing
he who conquers himself is the mightiest
warrior
ability will never catch up with the
demand for it
to see and listen to the wicked is
already the beginning of wickedness
before you embark on a journey of
revenge dig two graves
a youth is to be regarded with respect
how do you know that his future will not
be equal to our present
[Music]
fix your mind on truth hold firm to
virtue rely on loving kindness and find
your recreation in the arts
boldness without the rules of propriety
becomes insubordination
[Music]
fine words and an insinuating appearance
are seldom associated with true virtue
learn as though you would never be able
to master it hold it as though you would
be in fear of losing it
i am not one who was born in the
possession of knowledge i am one who is
fond of antiquity and earnest in seeking
it there
when you know a thing to hold that you
know it and when you do not know a thing
to allow that you do not know it this is
knowledge
[Music]
the faults of a superior person are like
the sun and moon
they have their faults and everyone sees
them they change and everyone looks up
to them
when a man's knowledge is sufficient to
attain and his virtue is not sufficient
to enable him to hold whatever he may
have gained he will lose again
to be able under all circumstances to
practice five things constitutes perfect
virtue these five things are gravity
generosity of soul sincerity earnestness
and kindness
do not be desirous of having things done
quickly do not look at small advantages
desire to have things done quickly
prevents their being done thoroughly
the will to win the desire to succeed
the urge to reach your full potential
these are the keys that will unlock the
door to personal excellence
there is no right amount of sex and
giving up sex for a long time shouldn't
have negative side effects
he with whom neither slander that
gradually sulks into the mind nor
statements that startle like a wound in
the flesh are successful may be called
intelligent indeed
there are three things to beware of
through life when a man is young let him
beware of his appetites when he is
middle-aged of his passions and when old
of covetousness especially
virtue is more to man than either water
or fire i have seen men die from
treading on water and fire but i have
never seen a man die from treading the
course of virtue
[Music]
if i am walking with two other men each
of them will serve as my teacher i will
pick out the good points of the one and
imitate them and the bad points of the
other and correct them in myself
to put the world in order we must first
put the nation in order to put the
nation in order we must put the family
in order to put the family in order we
must cultivate our personal life and to
cultivate our personal life we must
first set our hearts right
isn't it also great when friends visit
from distant places if one remains not
annoyed when he is not understood by
people around him isn't he a sage
[Music]
you